Every year grandkids cousins pretty much everyone gets together even great grandma Coco
I Tell her pretty much everything
Eat your food
Here have some more
No, Gracias
I mean si
That's what I thought you said
The animals winters has begun, it's the one night of the year our ancestors can come visit us
I thought I might've been one of those made-up things
Tonight is about family
I am not like the rest of my family. There's something that makes me different
Great-great-grandfather I want to be a musician just like you
All right who's in there. Uh I'm sorry
Welcome to the land of your ancestors.
Miguel, we're your family. You're skeletons! You're alive
You gotta get home before sunrise or you'll be
stuck here forever oh
It's show time
You my boy are meant to be a musician
I must follow my heart
I am trying to save your life
nice kitty
Miguel, something's not the more than you think
Sorry
We may have our differences, but nothing's more important than family
I'm proud of my family
Go away you. It's just painting never named a street dog. They'll follow you forever now go get my shoe
You